hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
seeing how we are still in the month of
nostalgia wheezes
I figure we will play a little game
simply known as the Stephen King
drinking game
good old Stephen King his pros are great
that his stories are crap
he has wonderful setups but
disappointing pails he creates some
great characters and fortunately you get
to see them over and over and over again
and one of the best ways to cease
continuing patters is to look at the a
stunningly long TV miniseries it
[Music]
based on the Stephen King book of the
same name it is another one of those
bills that looks to sir come to the
melodramatic cliches that always seems
to make it into every one of his stories
but what really surprises me is how many
people say they're actually afraid of
this movie and that's why I've invented
this drinking game to calm your nerves
there's a lot of movie to watch in a lot
of booze to drink so let's take a look
first of all take a shot if you're
Stephen King story takes place in May
well that didn't take long
yeah our story takes place in Maine
where everybody has a checkered past
bullies make up most of the population
and cheesy lightning effects reign
supreme in this particular town we come
across a girl who sees a rather unusual
sight Tim Curry and that's not scary
enough it looks like he's coming from
the black mass of Ronald McDonald
[Music]
so the kid gets murdered as Mike the
only black man in Maine notices that
this is the six recent child killing so
he calls up his old childhood friends to
let them know what's going on
he starts with Bill who grew up in to
the back of a horse's ass this is Mike
Allen bill from Derry this causes sin to
have a flashback which I'm not gonna
have you drink to every time it happens
because if you did you'd be dead in the
first 12 minutes don't bug somebody else
this is Bill as a young man played by
Jonathan Brandis piss off hmm he makes
his brother Georgie a paper boat for him
to sail outside thankfully it's the
sunniest rainy day in history so he can
go outside and enjoy it that is until
the missing member of the Insane Clown
Posse comes to join DS ride or lots of
surprises down here
there and getting surprisingly aroused
the more I talked about how much they
solved
so the kid gets eaten by a sloppy
dissolve effect as his sad brother goes
into his room feeling responsible and
it's fair to point out that this is
actually a creepy scene here the book
starts to have its time of a month when
bill calls for his folks to see it but
the parents surprisingly don't seem to
see the blood on the book what were you
doing in Georgie's room I don't want you
ever coming in here again son do you
understand how dare you try to mourn the
loss of your one and only brother come
back to the present day as Branagh bill
decides it's time to go back to me leave
have you lost your mind
we're in the middle of making a movie
they can replace me yeah if I saw Tim
Curry in a clown suit I probably leave
production to oh by the way just to
avoid future disappointment let's take
an early shot for a supernatural
creature who's never given the next
clinician of exactly what it is or where
exactly it came from Oh GLIP doom
meanwhile we cut to another childhood
friend named Ben played by John Ritter
would you believe I used to be fat a
regular butterball bet your fern I was
we should say that his kids
you bet your fern but I was f8000 fat
kids are hot tell me about your boy kids
hello hey Mike okay these flashback
transitions are getting a little silly
come back reader says no to his hole on
the go as he sits atop a tall building
and Ponder's his past about being the
new kid welcome to Derry Thank You mr.
Luce boink boink what a porker Henry
Bowers you will stay for one hour after
kugel every day this week now report to
the principal's office
you're dead fat boy but I'm going to
allow threatening his life is okay but
calling him a porker is simply going too
far so Ben meets up with a girl named
Beverly they seem to hit it off pretty
good but the chorus when grease has
other ideas I want to make here you
remember my name I'm not gonna make sure
oh I almost forgot
take a shot for the ones I meant to no
bullies that have no development or
redeemable qualities whatsoever silly me
I thought I came across one that had
some form of humanity no so he loses the
bully says he comes across the kids from
stand by me
I mean his classroom and of course they
become very good friends but that
doesn't help smooth things over with his
step family duty hey take a shot for a
heavy-handed slap against conservative
fundamentalist what that doesn't count
well surely this Gabby snot overblown
wine fest against Christianity I'll have
to read another why your stories to see
that religion is evil so Ben comes
across some sort of sewer entrance where
the evil clown is waiting for
grow up daddy yes my dear would I lie
[Music]
hello bloat so the clown doesn't really
hurt him or anything he just sort of
points at him and calls him fat what a
jerk
but we could to get another childhood
friend who gets a call Beverly who's
hitting the sack with a co-worker in the
90s who's so successful that his mullet
is almost reaching his knees I've gotta
go to Main
that was my handler phone you remember
to call it work today he's an old dear
friend I have to oh yeah I forgot
everybody in the Stephen King story is a
jackass except for the insecure poet
and/or loser I think that calls for
another shot why are you all spinning
you get into bed no but maybe you can
leave this house in Nice a moaning there
guy luckily a cab comes to take her to
our next flashback where we see that Ben
has looked a poem Ferger what you gonna
do nothing let me see that you've been
fooling around with some boy sometimes I
worry a lot daddy please
she's peach no matter what scene this
chick is in she's always getting a slap
in the face you'll get right down back
here baby
Oh course red max can't forget about the
rednecks that calls for a shot so she
meets up with Ben and heads over to the
huh and heads over to the rest of the
geeks and how chaos who pretty much make
up the only fucking decent people in
this town it's the River Nile and all
count them bowls Pink's is Ritchie toes
is my name and doing voices is my game
hey hello except green is playing a
funny geek who spends most of his time
doing voices I'm far too tipsy to make a
joke out of that so the gang gets
together and starts making a dam why
because it's fucking main and by god
that's as exciting as I guess he'll
there's even some famous jerk-off
writers who write about it that's how
exciting it is up there so we see Beth
and her father back at home and
alcoholic throw easy Stephen King
stories alcoholic so she'd go oh so she
goes to the bathroom sink where the
clown snot bubble clogs up her drain and
gets blood all over the place just like
before the grown-ups don't see it bloody
bugger sorry I think the alcohol start
going to my cameras anyway cut to the
next childhood friend getting a call
which appears to be Andy Dick searching
for his happy pills dirty little town
there's nothing for you there there
never was any why is it these people
have a talent for surrounding themselves
with the craziest fucking nut balls is
anyone in this world outside the main
characters likeable what kind of water
are they drinking in Maine to make them
such assholes
insert here's a big surprise another
flashback so we find out that Eddie was
the kid with the inhaler as we see that
his mother had a tight grip on him even
back then see you tomorrow
and it has to rest tomorrow don't you
play with me anymore no good will come
of it but mine and my friends need any
friends heavy except for your own ball
I think that's bad you should say his
brother speaking of showers sees and he
gets a doozy from the clown as he walks
in the shower room and finds out that
the showers in the gym are stretching
out and yeah that's about it
you can leave whenever he wants but
doesn't so
[Music]
oh no he's being attacked by the
California Raisins come on that's not
much it was horrible Here I am Weezy
come back anytime bring your friends
then what happened but you're gonna just
stop there
seriously come on fill us in did he just
stare at an awkwardly for the rest of
the time
so we cut to the Seth Green kid all
grown up when Oh hold on let me guess
the phone rings another flashback
happens we see Seth Green chased by the
bullies again big shock and runs into
the principal so he's ordered to go
downstairs and come back up with a mop
come but he's afraid because he suddenly
attacked by Teen Wolf
but the way let me guess again mmm he
turns into a killer clown talks about
his floating fetish shows off his sharp
teeth and then does nothing yeah well
doesn't he just eat these fucking kids
he's eating like half the other kids in
the neighborhood why doesn't he just
finish him off and what the hell is more
important in his time
get out of the boy oh my god it's almost
3:00 all right so you heard everybody
else's backstory where the hell is this
Mike guy who's making all these calls
fit in well guess what the answer will
be revealed in it turns out Mike was the
new kid on the block when of cars
he's a tagged by the Bowlings are these
the only fucking bullies in the town
come on kids give us kid hands across
the street chance the chicken lover a
fan says apparently they're immune to
barbed wire as he comes across the usual
gang of rejects so they throw rocks to
defend themselves as they discover that
bullies apparently aren't immune to pain
we talked about how they've all seen the
killer clown and discovered that he
might have been around for as long as
200 years this literally gets the
picture going as Mike's book comes to
life just to make the kids piss their
pants again
kill you all haha I get crazy and kill
you all sticks and stones may break my
bones but first you gotta throw up you
ever had
I am your work dream come true why don't
they just close the book when they'd be
able to shut him up if they'd just slam
that things shut crazy so they were to
destroy the clown as Mike back in the
present plans to make one more call
so Mike makes us less colonists and
resulting in Oh blow me if you don't
know courteous kind obedient cheerful
brave they find out that Bev is really
good with a slingshot so she's the
perfect candidate to shoot silver into
the monster friggin silver mother's
earrings baby salad so let's just stuff
in movies yeah that's just stuff in the
movies this is the killer clown that can
turn up sup into a werewolf you know
real life so they go into the sewer
where they think the clown is as it
turns out the bullies are there waiting
yeah I guess what they're not coming
back out did you get that audience okay
here we go so they're going to the sewer
to try and fight the monster this is
really suspenseful because I have no
idea which character is gonna make it
out alive except for all of them
now before you die I want you to think
about every rock you stopped up the
one-dimensional villain sees murder is
the only option that says every Stephen
King story
I'm gonna call better job hello friends
I invited a vitamin boy unless you gotta
run down let's let D pop out at Party
are you approval that's it
so this bright flashing light that's
supposed to be the clown I guess comes
in and kills two of the bully boys whoa
wait you forgot to scare them for two
months and brag about how things float
how well one kid is suck through a pipe
like Super Mario Brothers and the other
kid just turns into Billy Idol why
doesn't he just kill that kid because he
is a very stupid clown meanwhile the
kids hold hands because that apparently
weakens the monsters power it's like a
Care Bear special I guess when Tim Curry
pops up and finally tries to kill a
Bratz
[Music]
this is what you were afraid of the
whole time guys an acrobatic stop-motion
clown with a flashlight coming out his
hat not drunk good even I'm not afraid
so they think they killed it and make a
promise that if he's not dead they'll
come back to finish the job well as
years later the clown is back and we
find Stan is just a filthy cheater
oh no she dropped her can of beer beer
isn't that the drink that the movie
steel made famous
[Music]
oh gee that was nice of him to leave the
world's briefest suicide note did you
really feel that would explain
everything
oh wait before I go I should probably
explain the situation it and they can
figure out the rest room so I can bill
reunite as bill sees just how much has
changed and how much it's not changed
yours hey I'm a bachelor bill it's all I
need barely running around talking about
killer Klowns scares the ladies off
meanwhile Ritchie that Seth Green kid
gets a different kind of welcome come on
up Ricky it's those wonderful balloons
or even though no one can see or feel
them it still makes people somehow
flinch
excuse me sir can you see why y'all buy
the level poor guy up maybe because I'm
drunk or something but uh Tim Curry's a
riot
where people really scared by this guy
he's hilarious I don't even think he's
seen us supposed to be this long I think
he just decided to stay on set and annoy
everybody okay we'll just shoot around
you don't worry people he'll get
punished he's gonna be in Charlie's
Angels soon enough
both editing both has similar incidents
where the clown pops up and scares them
but again why doesn't he just Cuba
[Music]
boy they're really banking on balloons
being scary aren't they do they really
think that's gonna threaten people if
that's the case maybe this movie was a
stalker film okay so they meet up at a
Chinese restaurant for a nice big
reunion well the camera circles around
the table enough times to make you Pew
though to be fair maybe that's from this
obnoxious drinking game we see the only
surviving bully is now in a mental
institution where he's transformed into
Matlock up here remember oh hey it's a
beautiful Tim Curry out tonight
[Music]
meanwhile back in a restaurant we see
that the fortune cookies have been
replaced with Marilyn Manson's windup
toys which of course scares a living
shit up this leads them back to the
library where they tried to figure out
what the heck's keeping Stancil you tell
that loser that if he hasn't left
already he's a dead man
we all managed to show breathing in that
old derriere let me continue to be
incredibly inappropriate as we balut to
the obvious dramatic pay off in three
two one
Spanish did oh no we were assholes well
it's mourn his loss with another
flashback he said he didn't mean to go
into that house his voice kept
whispering to him
okay I must really be gone because that
looks like a mummy
seriously we're using mummies now this
isn't a Stephen King movie it's an
Abbott and Costello knockoff he was
trapped the only thing he could think of
to do was to hold his bird book out in
front of him like a shield and say as
loud as he could the names of all the
birds he could remember hold his bird
book out in front of him like a shield
and say as loud as he could the names of
all the birds he could remember our
mommies just allergic to the sound of
birds names I hadn't thought of it until
just now I swear he said I looked into
its dead lights and I wanted to be there
dead lights okay what is over these
stupid sound effects whatever there's a
flashback I mean while honey sound
effects do I looked into his dead lights
you looked into his dead lights I looked
into his dead lights what your own guys
yeah anybody else oh my god balloons
hide your blanket down balloons I
seriously will you knock it off there's
balloons everywhere in this picture
they're not frightening I mean come on
what is a blow never gonna look
intimidating
[Music]
so the scariest fuck balloons come out
as they see Stan's head is inside this
would be somewhat scary until I am I
well let's see who's here Richie you
still here we never expected you to
stick around
nice nose job no one would ever suspect
haystack but not a little weight huh
Weezy how's your sex life what's your
sex life this is pretty interest and a
pretty much every Dahmer's house we all
float down here and you will to know so
I guess they don't find the talking head
they're funny and they get the hell out
of there meanwhile we see the bully
escaped from the mental hospital by it's
the possibly scary
no I'm supposed to be funny
the doctor sever the class emotion that
was really supposed to be scary well
it's not it's not so after that okay
okay they figure out that the clown
attacks or feeds if you will on people
every 30 years oh and apparently the
whole entire town is in on it too how do
they know that get this because when Bev
was a girl getting beat up once an old
man went back inside yeah because that
one dick cheese didn't help her that
apparently means the whole town is crazy
I couldn't believe it he he just turned
around and went inside that was my
really hit me there was something
terribly wrong in dairy with dairy is
well anyway Matlock attacks Mike but
they managed to fight him off and kill
him they bring life to a hospital as bed
starts to analyze the situation why is
it doing why does it
why is so me if you would think that
it's like cotton killing cloud would be
a little nicer how could I be so blind
if you see it now you're not blind
anymore bad
boy this chick really gets around
doesn't she I mean I think she's
literally felt up every single person in
this group I could see why they hung out
with her she's easier to get into that
at our college we can't trust anyone if
anybody asks party got out of hand
dancing on the table you took a fall
anyone who's seen me dancing by that
well that's great and how are you gonna
explain the dead escaped mental patient
you're not seriously suggesting you walk
out of here and leave him lying there
you're not seriously suggesting we walk
out of here and leave it lying yeah
that's what I'm suggesting why don't you
call the police
this whole town is it in some way all of
them feels right really we're still on
this because one old fart went in and
jerked off that means the entire town is
crazy here's an idea you're all seen
killer clowns
maybe you're crazy did that ever occur
to you you crazy sacks of crazy crazy so
they'll decide to go back into the sewer
and kill this thing once and for all
so what kind of weapons are they
bringing you think I don't suppose
anybody thought to bring anything really
useful like a machine gun
it's the only thing I saved from those
days oh that's great they're bringing a
slingshot they can either bring a
machine gun or a slingshot Rambo or
Dennis the Menace gosh what the hell are
you gonna do now sing Kumbaya wake up
take a breath
you smell that that's death you hear the
wind that's death feel the ground that's
death you feel the itching in the back
of your head it's probably a mosquito
mosquito of death so they make their way
down to the retired Star Trek set where
Bill's wife happens to be trapped in the
cave yeah apparently she was heading to
Maine to bring her husband back and the
clown gather which is pointless seeing
how he can take on any farm but I
digress as they get to the heart of the
sewer they finally see the monster for
what he really is
[Music]
what what we waited three fucking hours
for that you can't be serious
you can't be serious if I heard that a
movie called it was just building up to
a big silly monster I think that's what
a better better payoff
I mean seriously seriously my god so
you're telling me this whole fucking
time we were building up to spiders a
Chinaman region of spiders
damn it dr. Smith this is really what
you and Stephen King find frightening is
that my dream is finally realized I what
smells like urinated whiskey oh yeah
it's me I've been playing the Stephen
King drinking game oh good god man
that's been known to kill people hey you
know what else has been known to kill
people you like the superhero the the
the yo whoa I'll just shoot myself oh
yeah you better run so yeah they're
fighting a giant spire and unbelievably
fake electing one too they all started
to get sucked into with dead lights
until Eddie has an idea this is battery
yet now you disappear
Wow that was a stupid idea guy maybe
that machine gun theory would have
worked after all so I think it's killed
by luckily Bev shoots it in the glowing
ball sag that seems to kill it oh wait
no sorry they tip it over like a cow
first and then they rip its heart out
truly this was a battle of wits so they
all go back home to the normal cells
except for Bill's wife who seems to be
in a zombie-like state because of the
giant spire
but somehow riding downhill on a bike
seems to make her better
[Music]
so yeah the character that had like two
scenes a few lines of dialogue and
barely any presents she's gonna be okay
yeah I know you're on the edge of your
seats about that but yeah she's gonna be
okay now
so of course all that build-up leads to
an unbelievable letdown which is the
ultimate staple of Stephen King which
means that gives us our very last shot
this guy stalks I mean the son with the
kids is tolerable because the kids
themselves are actually pretty good
actors and of course Tim Curry's a lot
of fun but half the adults are just
terrible the plot makes no sense it's
melodramatic as hell and it all suffers
from those Stephen King stereotypes
we've seen a bajillion times before and
plus what's with all the balloons
they're not scary why do they keep
thinking they're scary what were they
high any seriously Oh in the right mind
whatever bigger balloon is get
a critic I got a new script here tell me
what you think
[Music]
[Applause]
one so me